to end i actually i have a question that
i didn't email you that just occurred to
me as you all were speaking it's
something that professor 11 that you
said what are some aspects of your field
maybe their theories or concepts that
your peers are extremely resistant to
but you are not
wow um
dude i don't know if we got uh time for
all that but that's a lot that's a lot
that's a lot of stuff um i mean the most
basic there are many i mean the most
basic thing is this notion of uh
profound symmetries between these fields
uh you know this idea that you can um
that you can you can basically import uh
um
concepts and strategies from cognitive
neuroscience or behavioral science and
deploy them in other spaces
developmental biology and metabolism
that you can that it even makes sense to
talk about um you know goals memories uh
planning navigation uh all of these
kinds of things outside of what we're
used to which is some you know rad and
amazers or something like this so so
that continuum this idea that it goes
that that something important goes all
the way down or maybe a long way down
even if not all the way down that that
that is uh in in a few circles that's
okay in most circles that that i would
deal with that's just a that's just
complete you know complete heresy um
yeah there are many others but that's uh
that's kind of a basic one
chris
well i i think that mike really nailed
it with that answer
and
um
i would say
yes it's it's not
a popular idea that
physics and biology and psychology are
actually all more or less the same
science
but
i think that they are
[Music]
professor fristen
yeah well that would be my favorite
heresy i'm just going to agree with with
mike and chris you know the
physics biology psychology they're all
the same thing and i just wanted to end
by saying
uh you know heresy i'm not so sure
anymore i i you know the number of times
for example i see mike levin cited
in high-end philosophy journals and
treatments
suggests to me that in fact it's going
to be the minority um in at least in a
few years time that that don't subscribe
to this more holistic um um
encompassing um and i think
um correct way of viewing um
cellular life sciences but you're more
generally sort of the natural sciences
um
so
you know who is going to be the heretic
in a few years time i i suspect it won't
be any of us